[Music]
we should just tell the truth quickly
they're going to cut us off
there are some really bad things going
on here we cannot accept a culture of
silence
we have some breaking news right now
moments ago uba's national feed abruptly
cut to a test pattern we have to stay
together on this all the attention is
going to land on me
careful what you wish for right
let me make this simple we have to get
alex back she publicly left the show
new york new york
i don't want to i'm not coming back
they hurt me this is about them doing
things behind my back
it's all gonna work out don't tell me
it's gonna work out
there is a cost to success and fame
you're a dead man
said the corpse there will always be a
part of me that wants to be liked
i never wanted to be this person
things are supposed to get better
[Music]
everything changed in a minute the whole
world changed i thought we were a team
honestly bradley a friendship with you
seems like a bountiful journey
if i can't you talk to mitch
did he tell you that people deserve to
know the truth
nobody likes a gospel
there's been a lot written about the
morning show and
a lust for ratings that made even the
worst behavior permissible
do you feel that the important issues
have been addressed
[Music]
you